mark you have a choice  i have to finish this  that's not i'll never be free  with our disney plus series there were  characters who we wanted to introduce  for the first time  moon knight was at the top of that list  and we wanted a spectacular actor what  the hell's wrong with you steven stay  out of my way me you're the one going on  a killing spree  muhammad went for actors that i think he  just intuitively know commit  i loved mayum as an actress it was very  important for me  as an arab  to find someone who can represent this  being half egyptian myself it's great  that i get to play this mythical  character  he's a much more action-oriented  character in a way we haven't seen in  the mcu  the form  of movies  is changing it's a movie on a larger  canvas with that level of cinema and  quality i would never have guessed that  this would be one of my most creatively  fulfilling adventures it was just  amazing  oh man